- Welcome back yall...
- Action Kelly, go ahead, action, go ahead
- (laughing) you are dumb...
- And go.
- Welcome back everybody,
- we're live
- I have two more friends (chuckles)
I have two more friends
joining me right now.
She's an Oscar winning actress
and he's a Tiger King
loving, actor and comedian.
Together they're helping
feed health care workers
on the front line. Let's
say hi to Octavia Spencer
and Joe McHale yall. So, what's up guys
can y'all hear me all
right? Everything good?
- Where's the clapping? (hands clapping)
- The clap, this is our
clap, applause (laughs)
- Hello
- No but, how are y'all doing?
Coz I just, I think Octavia
your episode just aired
I think it was yesterday. So your back on.
Thank you for doing that. But,
what are y'all, how are you staying sane?
And, and you know isolation.
- I don't think I really am.
- (chuckles) me neither.
- I'm left with my own devices
you know, childhood stuff, trying to cook
for myself which is not good.
- I literally, obviously I've given up
this on every, look at my hair,
I'm letting it go
- You look great.
- You're a lair. But I love you..
- I do...
- So you've developed lying
in isolation (chuckles)
- You know I stay sane
by just remembering that
I was nominated for an Oscar and
- (laughing loudly)
and just being like,"I'm
amazing." (chuckles)
- No, no, I got to my
favorite old western movie set
and I put a blanket over the window
and I sit in the corner
of a wood building.
- (Chuckling) you're so weird
- Oh, Wait,
you're in my favorite room.
- This just, hey, I'll have you know
we had to fix this room up Joe
because we don't have anything
built here on our ranch,
so this is like an
unfinished cabin that we've like pretended
like we're totally fine and every...
The other, like if you could
see the other side of my camera
it's just unfinished wall but it's fine.
- Oh my God.
- Doing what we can...
I'll pay you to sit in
front of that tomorrow.
- (laughing)
- But Joe, isn't there something
that you wanted to tell Kelly?
- We wanted to say, Happy 55th birthday!
- Happy birthday.
- (laughing loudly)
- You look amazing! You look amazing.
- I do,
- Can we sing Octavia?
Let's do another round.
- (singing) Happy birthday to you...
- (singing) Happy birthday to you
- (singing) Happy birthday to you....
You've kinda cut up on my voice.
- (singing) Happy birthday
dear Rubin's daughter
- Oh my God you so...(laughing)
- (singing) Happy birthday to...you.
I got you a microphone.
- It is the best, best
of best birthday edition
but Joe you've been working
with Tiger King right?
You've interviewing all the people,
like for Netflix right?
- Yeah, no I, I, I,
I, I'm holding onto the
cocktails of that documentary.
They asked me to host the,
you know the kind of
wrap, the catch up special
and see where everybody
was that was agreeing
to be on camera and so they asked me
a few days before it aired and we
quickly scrambled together and got
they had a bunch of people
ready to be interviewed
so I, you know, I had barely anything
I was just happy to do it
because I loved the series
and was fascinated by
it, and I got to talk to
a lot of the folks involved and
yeah it's, after anything
I have done in the business
for the last 20 years, nothing
compared to the response
of that, I've never been a part
of anything that was that popular ever.
Combine the Soup and
community, not even close
to one 40 minute special... of me going
"How's Oklahama?"
So, that's basically--
- (laughing loudly) You are,
well, Octavia what have
you been binge watching?
- I've been watching Little Fires--
- I haven't seen that, I wanna
see that. Is that so good?
- Oh, so good, so good
- Yeah.
- I've actually been going back, like
I'm not kidding you. I'm
going back to simpler times.
I'm watching The Waltons and
- WOW!
- I love it.
- Little House on the Prairie, like
things before times of Corona.
- You're going to a,
you're in a dark place
if you're needing that kind of
you're like all the--
- I need it
I need it, I need--
- [Joe] You're going way back.
- I need it.
- Oh, no you're like "I need nostalgia
for whenever I can go ride
my bike and be outside--"
- I like how I'm going back before
Corona, I was like "you
could have done ER."
I mean that was...25 years ago
but you decided to go back
almost 40 years ago 50 years ago.
- Look. Aweseome. Hey Joe,
how is your podcast going?
- Thank you for asking.
- (laughing)
- It's with me and Ken Jeong and
it's called The Darkest Timeline, which is
a play on a community thing, from
a couple of years ago,
which is now on Netflix
and it's also because we're
in the darkest timeline
of this Covid thing and
Ken, is a real doctor
and his wife is a real practicing doctor.
And he knows, he is
very good at distilling
information down. So we
said, why don't we do this,
coz I'll talk to you
about what's going on with
the virus and then we can
answer community questions.
And so we talk about the
virus for about 10 minutes
and then it's an hour and a half of
we're just insult each
other and we've gotten to
a total of about four questions over
four episodes, but right
now it is literally
the number one podcast in the world.
- It is, that's incredible--
- It's not, I'm lying.
That's not true--
- No. I'm just saying
it is incredible though, I don't know,
I think, I don't think
ever to my, Ken Jeong
I forget he's a doctor--
- Yeah I forget he's a doctor.
- We've run into each
other several of times
and I just think it's incredible
that he has that kind of knowledge and
and also that presence and like,
the entertainment community
just to kind of keep
people's eye and attention.
That's really cool, I think it's cool.
- Yeah I'm glad he left--
- and y'all are both hilarious
- Yeah I know it's great
that he left a profession
of helping people and making people better
so he could ran around naked.
- Just make money. (chuckles)
- Yeah. No, He's a really great,
he's been a very close friend and now that
he's so old and has a hard time, you know
that I'm helping him. You know
it's like--
- Taking him home.
- All the time.
- (chuckles)
- I'm back with Octavia
Spencer gentlemen--
- (singing) Happy birthday to you Kelly.
Wait, we already did
that, sorry, go ahead.
- You did but I'll take it all the time.
Octavia I forgot to ask, how's Velma?
How's your wig doing?
- I've been looking for
Velma. I would have been
wearing her right now.
She's acting it out.
She knows Corona is serious and
she doesn't want any part of it.
I can't find her, anywhere.
- Bye bye.
Looks amazing. Alright well, let's
talk about the important issue
coz I do think this is really awesome
what y'all are doing, you're both
helping health care workers right now.
Joe you've been using your Instagram page
to help local restaurants, right?
- Again I don't know what
you're talking about Kelly.
- You're so full of...(chuckles)
- Okay, no, yeah I've been going around to
(mumbles) local restaurants around me
obviously and in... Los Angeles going
"Hey this is an independently owned place
obviously it's suffering, please come here
get take out, they have
great french fries,
they make a great steak,
they make a great...
motsibo soup." And to
just get some sort of
awareness of those places because,
there are so many independent bussinesses
that are gonna go down.
- Yeah.
- And the big guys, the big corporations
and the chains, yes it's
gonna be very hard on them
but they are gonna be able to survive
but this guys, they're
not, you know paying
they don't have to pay rent right now but
they're gonna be on the hook for it
when this is all over and
it's gonna be very tough.
So anything to support and then
the way that it happened is that
Melissa McCarthy and Ben Falcone
contacted me and said "
Hey, we've been talking
to Octavia Spencer," and then
Octavia you take it from here.
- And my friends Leslie Feldman
and Amy Carpenter and I,
we were trying to figure out a way
to do exactly what Joe was doing.
Feed the healthcare
workers on the frontline
but help the restaurants
in our communities.
And the communities of those hospitals
and then we decided to join forces
and then something better happened
Frontline Foods came along and
they were doing what we were doing
on a larger scale and
for so many more people
and they had a volunteer
army of over 300 people
and the five of us decided well,
we'd like to join that
army of over 300 people
where 100 percent of the
precedes go to all of
the restaurants to help
keep their lights on.
- Yeah and these are not, it's not that,
yeah, no restaurant is dow...
They're not donating the
food, they're being paid
to do what they do. So from the
person sweeping up the parking lot
to the surgeons, to
everybody coz you forget
that there is root..
there're people with cancer
that need their treatments and there are
all sorts of people that
need a medical assistance
and, the, you know our hospitals
are overwhelmed right now
and so it gives a little bit of relief.
And thankfully they reallly appreciate it
except we let Octavia
cook one of the meals
and it was--
- (chuckles) they sent it back
- A disaster. It was--
- (laughing)
Octavia you and I should both take
a cooking class together
coz I suck as well
so, (chuckles)
- Yeah, This one person with
the virus was like "Don't you
think I've suffered enough?"
- My kids are just looking
at me like very sad
like "can we have some other food."
And it's actually interesting because
a lot of us especially
a lot of moms at home
having to like sit in
the kitchen trying to
figure it out, the kitchen, that's where,
we keep making this joke at our house
but we keep saying like
"I just wanna support my
community right now and
order out." So I (chuckles)
- Nice.
- Really I don't wanna
cook but you're also
helping someone so--
- Yes!
- Here we are.
- Coz, you really are.
But we make the joke
coz we're just, I'm like
so tired of cooking
coz I'm not good at it.
But this is such a clever
thing that came together
with this Frontline Food, like it's so
clever how it's helping everyone involved.
It's a win-win. Even the
people getting the help
you're not, you're getting to help people.
That helps your spirit
and helps to like pull out
of that dark place we can sometimes go to
when we're quarantined so,
that's really incredible.
So this, the organization
has actually raised
over 1.6 Million Dollars donated over
50 thousand meals and
helps 135 restaurants
across the nation. That's like so cool.
I mean you two, I hope
y'all, I know you're not
doing it to be like
proud of it, but that's
really cool, that y'all--
- No, I'm doing it.
I delivered 50 thousand meals alone.
- (laughing) I did all of it
- I'm exhausted.
- No, I think, probably
like, there was this
whole flurry of work
while we trying to put
this thing together,
it was gonna be called
Comfort Food 2020, and then, Octavia
I don't know who discovered Frontline,
but they were like "(mumbles)"
like we weren't a day
in and all of a sudden
the aircraft courier showed up and said
"wanna ride?" And we were like "yes."
- Yes we do.
- What would y'all say
to those who out there
who are watching this
right now, who wanna help?
Like how could they help and
aid in what y'all are doing?
- Well they could go to frontlinefoods.org
- Okay.
- Kelly.
- If some people don't have
money to give right now Kelly
so I would say if you
don't have money to give
a simple prayer goes a long way too.
- Well thank you so much Joe and Octavia
for getting involved. For more
info on how you could help
go to frontlinefoods.org
and look for Joe in a new episode of
the Twilight zone on CBS all access
and he's the voice of Johnny Cage in the
up coming movie Mortal Kombat
Legends Scorpion's Revenge.
and also catch Octavia
in the Netflix movie
Self Made inspired by the
life of Madam C.J. Walker